is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable
no it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300
000 well-equipped as well as quipped as
any army in the world
and an air force against something like
75
000 taliban it is not inevitable here's
what will will will happen is the
taliban will begin to mass at some
point to take down the major cities in
afghanistan holding back quite now and
i think until the united states is
pretty much all gone
and then we'll see that let's bring in
our panel to discuss that
molly hemingway senior editor at the
federalist harold ford jr former
tennessee congressman and ceo of
empowerment and inclusion capital
and bill mcgiren columnist for the wall
street journal let's start right there
molly the president says a couple of
things he does not trust the taliban
he also says listen they're a smaller
force only 75 000 versus possibly 300
000 in the afghan army but
they've been very effective uh even with
their smaller numbers
you know this is really about so much
more it's about how we fight wars and
what we're thinking
almost 20 years ago that our friend
charles krauthammer gave a speech
in which he said that it would be good
to spread democracy from north africa
to afghanistan he noted that many
conservatives thought it wouldn't work
and he said it might not work but he
thought we should give it a try
we have given it a try we have given it
a very long try it has cost trillions of
dollars
thousands of people's lives have been
lost and the nation of afghanistan
might not be able to make it even after
we've invested so many resources
but really what is important is that the
united states understands that when the
way that we fight wars
we have to have clear metrics of success
we have to understand why we're there
and we have to move away from nation
building into fighting wars
that are solely in our national interest
or laser focused on our national
interest
and so all these questions about how
things are going to go in afghanistan i
think missed that point
that we tried this experiment and it did
not work
and the president was asked today about
whether this was a mission
accomplished moment that's what i think
people across the world and certainly
here
at home in america want to hear did we
accomplish something what did we
accomplish here's what the president
said on that point
if this is a mission-accomplished moment
what is it
no there's no mission accomplished
the mission was accomplished in that we
get us got osama bin laden
and terrorism is not emanating from that
part of the world
yes but harold how concerned should we
be now uh that some of those forces
could reconfigure there because it's not
just the u.s leaving there are other
good actors also leaving
a very troubled area
i'm sorry thanks for i can hear you uh
look i agree largely with the predicate
that molly has articulated
i think it is you know 20 years 4
trillion dollars
we've made progress there i do think we
have found that the
culture and persistent history of
tribalism has undermined our efforts to
bring about the kind of unity or
centralized government
and government in afghanistan that we
want but also consistent with molly's
points 20 years later technology has
grown satellites drones
we'll be able to prosecute this effort
protect our interests
and ensure the one thing that we don't
want to see happen which is
that that those grounds there in
afghanistan the taliban again becoming a
haven
for terrorist organizations if that
happens i would imagine this
administration would follow the lead
of itself and general keenan and others
who urge that we'd be able to get back
on the ground there
because at the end of the day our focus
has to shift uh
china presents itself as that a
geographical economic and military
threat
uh that we're gonna have to focus on
much like we focus on russia during the
cold war in the 20th century
yeah and the president today did not as
you noted um
say that we would never go back that
american troops would never be called
back into that arena
the washington examiner writing about
that said this the implication
should the taliban fight their way back
to running the country
washington might conclude that it is
acceptable so long as it does not harbor
extremist groups
such as al qaeda the islamic state group
or others that might plot attacks
on the u.s its interests abroad or close
allies but bill it seems that throws us
back into the same calculations we're
always having to make
about how much we let the quote-unquote
bad guys
have a say or you know a hand in running
the country when we have worries about
things that will impact our interests or
those of our allies
yeah look shannon i was in afghanistan
with the mujadin
way back before this war in the first
war in afghanistan when they were
fighting the soviets
and you know i'm old enough to i'm old
enough to remember vietnam
i'm old enough to remember um you know
the reformation of like isis
after we led the area so i i wish i
could be optimistic
but i can't the last time we thought
afghanistan didn't matter
you know they came and knocked down two
of our buildings
in manhattan and attacked the pentagon
and i just don't believe
that the air capabilities are going to
be sufficient look what happened in
benghazi
because our flight it took hours for
flights to get there
i just don't think you can substitute
for troops on the grounds we had i
believe
three casualties this year none of them
combat related
you know we're still in germany after
defeating hitler
and we're in korea and japan after world
war
ii and that's been to our benefit to
help stabilize the region
i i just think this is going to go down
as a terrible mistake
well the president did talk too about
these calculations about why to get out
how to get out when to get out
i'll play a little bit more of what he
had to say on that front today
the u.s military mission afghanistan
continues through the end of
august let me ask those who want us to
stay
how many more how many thousands more
americans daughters and sons
are you willing to risk i will not send
another generation of americans to war
in afghanistan
with no reasonable expectation of
achieving a different outcome
the united states cannot afford to
remain tethered to policies
creating a response to the world as it
was 20
years ago and molly that gets to your
point
about trying an experiment seeing
whether it works what our role
is there do you think the president has
articulated well about
the reasoning for leaving now i actually
think he did a great job with it i want
to commend him for staying strong under
so much pressure from the
military-industrial complex
also that president trump set that
deadline which which helped
get this going is very good more than
anything though it's a reminder too
about how that same military
how the brass did not do a good job of
preparing for exit
one of the ways they kept us there for
so long was by never really developing a
strategy for how to leave
and it would trap presidents into
staying and we're seeing some of the
fallout of that now but
president biden is doing the right thing
by not allowing that to continue and
insisting that we stick with this plan
and uh and hopefully things will go well
from here on out but it was long fought
for by many people so kudos to him
yeah and john kirby said yesterday the
the whole idea is is
getting towards a negotiated peaceful
political solution to this whole thing
but harold when a lot of people say they
can't trust the taliban as
you know a negotiating partner at the
table
how does that resolution eventually come
about
right if we stayed indefinitely or
stayed a longer period of time i don't
mean to put words
in bill's mouth but if we stayed the
taliban is not uh gradually becoming a
more trustworthy organization what we're
finding is that
we have other priorities we can manage
the situation with with new technology
and hopefully
we don't have to find our way back there
uh but i think this is the right thing
to do it's a painful it's a tough
decision
uh and i expect the military to counter
the president some on this
but hopefully they reach an agreement
within our military and white house that
if there's a problem we can get back and
get back quickly
and let's hope that we don't have to go
back and we're able to manage this
situation
and get on to dealing with china and our
other foes
a quick closing comment to you bill on
this topic
well weren't the south vietnamese
reassured that if something happened the
u.s would be back there to do it
i'm not sure the new technology helped
much in benghazi
when those guys were out of reach of air
support
i hope they're right but i again this
looks to me
like it has a lot of wishful thinking
behind it